do you guys know that there's different
hot dogs now at dodger stadium they
change brands
do you know you know what i'm so glad
that you brought that up me too
it went from circumcised to
uncircumcision
hello everyone hola mis amigos
you're listening to oh my god hi
with me george lopez
let's do the show
right phelps
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
george
george lopez oh my god omg omg hi
thank you to one of our favorite
sponsors here better help h-e-l-p help
better help is customize online therapy
that offers video phone and even live
chat sessions with your therapist
listeners of the omg high podcast get 10
off their first month at betterhelp.com
omghi
that's b e t t e r h e l p
dot slash omg hi
in a podcast first george has asked us
to get started he's on his way he's
running a couple minutes late so uh i'll
introduce our guest we may have to
introduce you again but
for for the first time we have joining
us on the podcast chase bernstein
comedian uh podcaster on your website
you're described as comedian writer etc
which i love
um
can be seen on netflix as the wedding
coach bill burrs the ringers all across
the internet um chase bernstein thank
you thanks for having me well thank you
for joining us today you know i was
really excited you know in watching you
on youtube today something yeah and
talking to you you don't do very often
but i watch it you're local you're from
the valley yes and that you made fun of
the way you talk that's why i talk the
way i talk
yeah
and i don't know what you're referencing
that's on there i mean i know the joke
i'm just like i don't even remember
uploading that set but like i i trust it
it was good thank you there was nothing
there was nothing derogatory nothing
meaning nothing nasty all very
complimentary thank you
so does the the valley girl the valley
voice whatever you want to call it did
you feel like that because it's a little
bit part of your brand right or well i
mean this is how i talk okay and that's
what i was gonna ask you
is that was that in your nature did you
find yourself like leaning into that
from a comedy perspective do you resent
how people like joke about uh just
curious your whole take on that well i
mean i guess i only have that one joke
about it and i actually it's a good joke
i mean no offense but it is a good joke
but it's like i i actually don't like
being like oh
you know call out something of how i
talk or whatever it's kind of just like
i mean i don't do that joke much anymore
but because it's like i don't i don't
need to like
draw attention to it necessarily because
it's already there you know it's like
for sure
[Laughter]
[Music]
um i don't know i mean it's just is what
it is you know it's like i have always
wanted a southern accent like i feel
like that would be a really good time
green accent it's so true it's so good
like i just feel like every if you had a
southern accent i would just talk so
much more
you know
i don't know i don't care what i sound
like
as long as people listen i'm happy yeah
whatever whatever works works yeah we
got to keep we got to keep rolling on
this stuff so what do you like doing
more do you like
writing do you like the stand-up side i
like being preferred etc etc is you know
it's everything to me but
i like doing stand-up the most
um
you know it's just the most
gratifying it's instant
you know
without going into age how long have you
been doing it
uh
this year will be 12 years wow yeah you
don't look that old not at all crazy i
know
where does the time go crazy
uh yeah
and so how long have you been do you
tour much at all do you get around the
country do you still yeah i mean i was
just i just came back from mexico
yesterday yeah last night see any
mexicans
i mean i caught a few you know like
yeah it was really fun when you when you
were in mexico were you entertaining
predominantly mexicans or people on
vacation it was actually so i thought it
was going to be a lot of tourists but it
was actually a lot of american
people just live there now i guess i was
in cabo and because i was like you know
asking people are you like are you here
on vacation they're like no [ __ ] like
we live
here okay wow like i didn't see it
coming but it was really nice because
you know obviously things translated
because i have done i did a show in
mexico city once and
you know that that didn't go over too
well like there was really yeah
but i mean just because it's how much do
you think it's very language yeah like
they truly didn't like we don't really
speak much english yeah and it's like
you think even that it's like okay well
i know that so it's not personal to me
it's not like they don't like the jokes
it's like they don't really understand
me but it still stings
you know
oh yeah still recovering
yeah
but um cabo was fine
how long did you stay over there
uh just a couple days i went friday i
did two shows it came back last night
and here i am in burbank i mean i'm just
like you made it now you're in burbank
yeah it doesn't get any bigger better
than this
and so how long have you been able to to
tour how long were you sort of just
doing stuff locally and then at what
point were you able to get out i mean i
guess i guess i started did i start
featuring i've started featuring for
melissa via senor
um in
probably 2015. i mean before that we
were going you know like
we'd go to san diego or you know local
spots brea and stuff but then
yeah she started taking me
we started flying and i was like oh wow
like we're flying you know yeah yeah so
yeah probably probably 2015.
and then how how did you melissa meet
her how did you guys sort of get linked
up for the working relationship uh i met
her i mean i met her at open mics but i
had just started and she had already
been
doing it for
quite a while like i think she started
when she was like 17 or something
um but so she but she would still go to
open mics even though she was like doing
shows and you know she's gonna do
america's got talent but yeah i just met
her at you know
like you know 4 p.m
like north hollywood open mike like yeah
and we just recently had guests one of
which
was on america's got talent okay uh
comedian who's uh vicki barbalak i don't
know if you know shoot i'm not familiar
she's a trailer parker
they're not like a duo but they're all
they're beautiful okay cool they just
they just launched a podcast called
trailer park diaries if anyone wants to
check i love it and it really she really
went quite a ways
oh yeah oh cool she she didn't she
didn't win it yeah but she was amongst
the finalists oh yeah that's uh i i like
to watch that show
non-violent
yeah no it's pretty good you've had
enough of that kill you've had enough of
that
and that's how you recognize her too
right you're like why did you look so
familiar exactly i told you
america's got talent wow
really really powerful
so your uh your podcaster yourself i
mean yeah
you know i have a show on this network
called composed
and uh yeah started in the pandemic you
know
got bought a microphone off amazon like
i'm like how hard can it be you know
fired up garageband and just here i am
what are your podcasts about
um
it's just kind of me talking you know
just whatever happened that week it's
you know i'll do i'll kind of write
these emails to like a different kind of
subset of people you know
it's it's a really fun format like it's
i just always even might just see like a
title it's one of your episodes i'm just
yeah yeah so i was like i never thought
of that
yeah
like i think one the other week i did
was you know it was like dear people who
refuse your offer to have the seat
warmer on
i'll let that sink in
did you call my wife before
not like you
water she doesn't like it oh my god
she doesn't like it
and she doesn't look
yes i like it exactly
i like to see blower when it's hot
exactly even if it's hot it's like okay
seat warmer windows down it's like let's
get a best of both worlds like i'm just
like baffled when people decline the sea
warmer and i'm so like now my car has
seat warmers so i'm so excited when
people come in to you know even be able
to offer such a luxury and then people
are like i'm good and i'm like
wow just a couple of days ago it's 101
degrees outside oh yeah and she's trying
to reach over i have a cadillac escalade
she says your seat's on
and she starts and i got her and i said
yes it is leave it alone and she said
well no you want to see one i said
that's the blower dear
keep your hands on
the instruments on your car don't touch
mine yeah the blower yeah so that's what
it's there for exactly and it's like
even just like to heat the back it's
like get them look at the muscles
relaxed you know it's like it's sort of
like a medical thing as well like i'm
just
i love my seat warmer the only thing the
only thing i have to worry about
is when people are in the ba if i have
passengers in the back seat okay i guess
it gets the feet rather hot
down there when you turn to eat you got
it so hot you have like an aura of yeah
the cadillac version must be pretty
pretty intense i mean i just have a
honda you know so it's like we're just
we're keeping room temp but actually it
does get pretty hot but not by the feet
that's it that's
yeah the feet in the back backseat
passengers it has to blow it has to be a
lot look at this booty i mean
get this booty warmer got its work cut
out for it
so is is the blower the opposite of the
warmer then yeah
unlike the heat warmer which i will
never turn out i would have the blower
on like when i wasn't even in the car
i'm about that bluntly you get in that
car in a cold morning you turn the
heater on the seat heater on a wheel it
doesn't take you long wait there's a you
have a wheel heater yeah
i'll get up right now
can you take a turn off your car after
wait so like you got in your car you
know it's a breezy los angeles night and
you're like i just need like the mitts
are cold yeah like i need to just take
long at all
wow
god i gotta get a cadillac
do you see that for me i do it's amazing
what adding heating does to that that
was in my bucket list it really was yeah
i retired 13 years ago and i didn't get
my first cadillac until the year i
retired wow i always wanted one that's
so cool you got it though yeah yeah i
wanted one and i wanted floor shine
shoes
and because floor shine shoes
those are the best that you know that
best shoe around i bought them first
pair i bought i threw away i felt
terrible here oh my god
did they i mean do you think the shoes
didn't fit or was it just i think it was
just a bad style bad fit yeah so but i
didn't want to mess with anymore yeah
yeah the only other one i had i had
three
three things for my bucket list get a
cadillac floor shine shoes and own a
harley and so i drove a harley for a
while i loved it oh my god do you still
have it or you have to do no i had rid
of it i had to depart with it one year
my daughter my old family feedback
direct two cars oh okay and neither one
were her fault but they were both used
cars
so they didn't pay much on the used cars
yeah so at the beginning of the year i
had one harley and three cars
the end of that year i had one harley
and one car
and so i wasn't gonna let anybody take
my harley so i had to get rid of my my
toy and ironically when i bought the
harley
my wife was pissed
and i don't care if she hears this
she was just
she was pissed when i bought it
my son went out there and said dad cool
and she pinched him
and i said don't take it out on a kid
it's my harley i bought it
so that was my harley the day that i
sold it
she stood out there and she cried
really and i said you're pissed off when
i buy it
now you're crying when i sell it she
said well i just saw how much fun
it brought to you because the first
thing she said is not a family car over
here these past few weeks when i was
seven
to see tearing up right now i i just she
said when i bought it it's not a family
vehicle i said no
it's not but we don't have to do
everything with the kids every time we
go out you want to jump on a bag jump on
a bed
and as it turned out
the only time i could ever go in a place
by myself
was when the family was gone
because if not somebody wanted to jump
on the back including the wife you know
it and it was fun
with the stresses of the job that i did
it was a stress reliever
to go on out there and ride and just
have fun
and
so
i rode it
from the third car went
i sold it to a friend of mine
and when i sold it to a friend of mine
the first thing i did was get pissed off
because
i used to keep mine
super clean i mean i'd lay down on the
ground with a toothbrush and clean out
everything and it had to be
super clean yeah and i sold it to him
and i looked i said
you piece of [ __ ] what did you do to my
i mean he wasn't caring for it as much
as i did yeah
but
it went to good use were you ever a um i
mean a motorcycle cop would you ever
like no ride for on the job or i never
did motorcycle cop
i was actually as a patrol cop i was i
was intimidated by bikers when i was a
kid my grandmother had
a restaurant in san bernardino
big place for hell's angels and they
used to come in there as a kid i s
that'd be jesus would be i'd be i'd be
scared to death
when i became a cop
i'd had some run-ins with
mongols and else angels
in doing my job
and then i took one to jail one time
and when i took him to jail he had to go
he was uh
start peeling his clothes off well he
was big you know bad with all these
clothes you start
unlayering him and he was a skinny
little guy
and he's just normal human beings like a
nesting doll
so i found out they're just human just
like anybody else
so i never never did
right but i did
have leathers you know and the chaps and
and all the regalia that harley riders
have to have oh yeah and and i remember
going by the rose bowl being stopped by
by a cop by the rose bowl
and as he came up as i'm taking out my
license he saw my badge and he says oh
he says okay forget it folded i'm sorry
he'd probably work another cover i said
i am
he thought i was a uc yeah
if anyone ever gives you the benefit of
the doubt and assumes you're under cover
for something just saying he said it not
me very kind of him thank you wherever
you are today
[Laughter]
so i had it i loved it
uh i bought it and
had it for three years
then i had to sell it
and so it went off to harley heaven
and now because i get dizzy every once
while
i'm afraid to buy one another yeah but
do you still have the chaps
no
i could hear the fans out crying as soon
as
we need the chats i remember there was a
beautiful i get called to do a lot of mc
work for the department so
they asked me if i would do a uh
motorcycle uh
fundraiser
for
deputies or anybody killed in law
enforcement they were raising money to
to give them and
and it was harley davidson the starting
point harley davidson to long beach
then i went down there and they had this
gorgeous bike
and it had gill written all over it
and i was feeling good and he comes out
he says you know
this looks like it has your name on it i
said god i wish i could
i said but my wife ain't gonna have no
no part of this
he said well you don't know until you
won't ask her i said i know my wife
you're not gonna have it yeah so
he says
what do you think give it a try
so i took a picture of it
and i sent it to her i said what do you
think
she says god that's beautiful she says i
like that better than your first bike
and he said well there you go
that's permission i said no it ain't
[Laughter]
i know my wife
so i i text her back and i said hey does
this mean you give your approval to buy
it and i'm not going to be in trouble
yeah and she says as soon as i get my
breast augmentation
you can buy the bike
okay i said okay
and i killed it on the credit card and i
looked i look at him i said see i
already knew there's the answer that
that's a definitive note with my wife
right so i left for the day i'm on my
way home and i just told her i said hey
what are you doing wednesday morning she
says
i don't have anything on the book i said
okay well then 10 o'clock says what
happened 10 o'clock i said i have an
appointment with the doctor to do your
breast augmentation
and she says you're full of [ __ ] you're
not buying that bike
oh my gosh
you didn't have to reconnect those dots
for him
well i'll put on my george hat a little
bit i know he likes to ask how um you
know how comedians found their way into
comedy like what what was your sort of
path you know you have to be crazy to do
this [ __ ] that's kind of a test too like
how did you sort of find it and how are
you finding it um i think i just kind of
fell into it actually it was not in my
plan i mean i didn't have a plan but it
definitely wasn't something i set out to
do um
i was actually just doing some comedy
writing just because it paid like i i
just i wanted to be a writer and
i found some job that i was comedy
writing and it was like the only thing i
paid so i was like okay i'll do comedy
writing you know what sort of stuff were
you writing at the time um it was just
like blog posts you know like it was
just it was this website called matt
adams that was like affiliated with fox
and they would pay
50 an article so that was the only
reason i started doing it in the first
place like just for money and then i
realized it was kind of like a whole
world and i started to kind of really
love it and then
started doing improv and then i met
um or i was on an improv team with
awesome folly i don't know if you guys
know him he's a really
funny stand comedian and he was like i
think you should do stand up like i
think you might be good at it and i was
like i was like you know truly like an
aunt like i was like what stand up like
i really like was so
foreign to all of it and he just gave me
like a list of open mics and one night i
went to one and that was just it like i
quit my job so i caught the bug right
away oh yeah instant instant and then
here i am
thriving 12 years
yeah
yeah that for show go go well were you
like i need more of this this feeling or
did it like go not so great and you're
like i gotta prove you bastards wrong or
no i mean it was just like an open mic
you know and i think it was nice like i
went towards the end so it was like i
got to watch people because i think i
assumed everyone who did stand up was
really good at stand up and then i went
to this open mic downtown laughter from
the background yeah and i was watching
people and i was like i mean no offense
i was like oh i was like well i mean i
could at least be that bad at it like
it's like i could be on the same level
of bad as them you know so
that was that i think a lot of people
get into various like hollywood pursuits
because they see someone do it they're
like i could at least be that bad yeah
yeah i mean and it's like because you
know
it was an open mic it wasn't like a show
you know it was like they could have all
started like a week before me but i just
like assumed they were
you know seasoned professionals how long
do you do in an open mic um this opened
my this first one i think i did three
minutes it ranges from about three to
five minutes like five is you know a lot
to get at an
open mic
you know
which is not long at all but actually
when you start five minutes does seem
like an eternity
and now sort of how how long of a set
are you doing these days do you have i
mean you have like a half hour an hour
or five yeah i mean that's your sort of
setup i definitely have an hour but you
know i feature for people a lot so i'll
do like 25 30. um how do you in terms of
like the process how do you go about
writing an hour when you have
25 minutes of time like how do you sort
of figure out how do you lengthen it how
do you connect the dots i'm just curious
what that's what it looks like for you
um i mean i don't have too much of a
process i just like i do whatever jokes
i'm excited about
because it's just hard to fake it if
you're not you know so i'm like
i just do it i look at it and i'm like
okay i like this one i like this one i
like this one and then i'll just kind of
i mean i'm really just winging it i
don't like if someone could let me know
i i actually don't know
i don't even know how it's clean or dark
pretty clean yeah
i like dark
i've never had someone say dark
i'm like usually people say blue but um
i like dark
no i i keep it pretty clean pretty light
you know
that's how much i know about the
business of darkness i like dark it
sounds more intriguing i mean where does
blue even come from why does that mean
you swear blue
yeah i think it's like dirty or you know
yeah we all think of the color blue yeah
yeah i don't know i think i thought i
understood it at one point but now
they're asking me i don't
know georgia is making fun of me you
should call it a dark right now usually
my job would be to look up the origin of
this while george is talking oh yeah
i hope i'm the first person on this
podcast that george lopez isn't even
here for
like they're like i was on the tourism
it's like it's called omg high but you
actually never even got to go to him
but this is a good time as well
this is kind of fun for me you know yeah
you're really
this is hey you're like you still got
you got a gl and a gill so that's where
we're filling in the gaps oh cool let me
see
i found something that's explaining why
it's blue but it's taking forever to get
there it can't it can't go that well
otherwise
george
we'll never let us do it again i'll take
over yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
what's on the agenda today
right now we were just talking comedy
all right
thank you that's a tally huh let's talk
i've been out of state a few times
oh wow
you dressed up for us nintendo thank you
i appreciate it so much
um if he's not wearing a jimmy world
shirt something's gone wrong man i gotta
go have that dude go get those baseballs
cheers yeah cheers um
do you come from a family of alcoholics
let's get two of them
dollar friday anybody that can sneak in
a file through my relatives
[Laughter]
so
you know it's i'm always interested in
because you know i'm already rehearsing
in the car i love it what did you guys
watch growing up as a family wow okay
that's a great question
i mean right out the gate
you know what's going on sizzling but
also you know where
where families want to be together and
watch tv yeah
my
grandmother and grandfather would watch
the same channel in the living room and
i would be watching the same tv in the
den
and never did they say why don't you
turn that off and come watch it in here
with us yeah yeah and we would watch all
the family and my grandmother go he's
funny but he's mean hi george yeah
grandma
went to the exact same program
it's like nobody and nobody ever thought
to say
or i never thought to say hey you guys
don't mind if i come and watch all the
family with you guys right did you want
to or you wanted to like yeah you wanted
to be so loud i mean i'd want to be in
the den
because everybody used to watch in the
60s would watch ed sullivan or something
like that together but i don't know that
i watched too much with my family you
know it's like i watched a lot with my
siblings but like i don't know it's like
a whole unit if we really
got into much and are you from new york
no but i'm honored i mean do i seem like
i'm foreign
no anytime a latino sees somebody in
flannel you think they could throw
where did you grow up in studio city
yeah now i was
i might have been off by 3 000 or so
much
and did you work with the first club
that you went to and how
you know because when people start to
get into stand-up there always has to be
oh yeah and whether you're a fan of
comedy or or not
or
there has to be like a seed of somebody
saying but it's it it's the most
frightening thing to do yeah i think
yeah when you're especially when you're
starting because you're not very good
but yet you have to keep going back to a
place where you're not very good yeah
yeah a company would fire you if you
were at the market
you put the meat where the seafood was
they're like hey man you know what you
gotta go bro you can't you don't even
know where to put the meat you keep
putting the salmon where the meat goes
and since you don't know anything
it you just have to just keep going back
until something kind of connects just
delusional did you start at um
you got it
local
the one-on-one
yes oh my god
that's an extra guilt
you and your you and your dog growing up
i see some peanut butter and a lot of
licking
[Laughter]
that was my second open mic
so
we had that basketball guy on return
basketball so as
as errors go by again this episode
yeah
everybody starts to forget
the the previous
like i go back to
you know you could go back to toady
fields on mike douglas i could go back
to elaine boozler i could go back to to
joan rivers
i could go to um
bob saget
i know you started out with in 1979 bob
saget i met harry mandel
i met uh uh letterman was out there
uh i told you that story but i let her
know when i saw david letterman i was
too nervous to ask him for an autograph
so a homeless guy walked by and i said
hey man
i'll give you five dollars if you go ask
that dude for his autograph and he came
back it skipped stevenson he missed it
by one you know
gotta give another five dollars
and i said the other one and he of
course there's no tact you know he
doesn't you know doesn't wait
to
to you know until there's a lull in the
conversation he gets a pen like that's a
letterman and he signed that said oh he
signed it
and and letterman wrote beat it you
deadbeat david brenner
but but you know my your errors like who
who were you who's your role model or
your influences uh and were they from
social media
no it was this i started in 2010
so it was maybe like kind of right
before like things were like popped off
you know it's like i had twitter but
like that was about it
and
you know you you're
seems to be a rather smart girl very
attractive what in the devil would make
you go and do
stand up like why i don't know like it
just i i didn't plan it i really just
fell into it and i started going and i
really just became obsessed with it and
it really just felt so right like
nothing i didn't know what i wanted to
do like nothing was speaking to me and
then i started stand up and i was like
okay unfortunately this feels right
and you know some people
you know 40 years earlier would follow
the grateful dead everywhere
and she was like i wanted to stand up
and it just felt like i was in the right
place yeah yeah
haha yeah
and how did you start to write how did
you start to write it like where was
your
what was you what was coming out what
needed to come out
i don't know i mean the first year it's
like it was so off you know like i was
just writing stuff just to like
see if i could get a punch line but it's
like i didn't actually feel connected to
any of it you know i'm just like saying
it
and then like not until like a few years
and i'm like what the hell am i talking
about you know yeah and i was just like
okay this is not i can't sustain this
was it personal to you or because you
know a lot of times
somebody will be
because you're afraid to
like if you were playing the the
a keyboard like the center of the
keyboard is where all the good notes are
but you play over here because you're
right you're not you're really not ready
to go here yet you know um
and the worst thing a comedian can do
and which a lot of a lot of comedians
are is if you go see a comedian
and
in the car
you say man that dude was good which one
the third guy the third guy which guy
was that guy
and if you don't leave him with
something to remember like you know
almost clothes are always tight so when
you see more more you'll be like that
[ __ ] dude was up there the [ __ ]
shirt was tight huh not really material
yet just the tightness of his clothes
but but i remember i was i was one that
would say
like
uh what i used to open with um
well i opened with
now i open with the secret service
coming to
visit me for a joke that i made about
our former leader
and that iran had offered allegedly 80
million and then i went up and said
we'll do it for half
because we're latinos and they took that
as a threat and i told them it was an
estimate it all wrote itself
and they said if we come back you're
looking at 10 years of federal
penitentiary i said i was married for 17
years i could do 10 years on my head
so it kind of wrote itself you know when
you feel the right vibe of it like music
you know yeah you know uh
you know there's a difference
between know seeing somebody at the
greek theater and seeing somebody at
stephen steakhouse
right
so
is it uh is it what's you what what are
you uh
what are the things that you dislike
what do you mean do we talk about things
that we in comedy
comedy's about when things go wrong and
not go right
no we really just started talking about
comedy and sort of heard your start when
you walked in so we have not had
dislikes at all we touched on seat
warmers harley's
i mean you know roger the dodger peanut
salesman right here
support for the omg high podcast is
brought to you in part by better help
online therapy
people don't always realize that
physical symptoms like headaches teeth
grinding and even digestive issues can
actually be indicators of stress
and don't forget doom scrolling sleeping
too little sleeping too much under
eating overeating really doing too much
or too little of anything these can all
be sort of symptoms of stress stress
shows up in all kinds of different ways
and especially in our world one that's
telling you to do more all the time
sleep less and just grind grind grind
here's your reminder from us to you to
take care of yourself maybe do a little
less and maybe try some therapy
it's a super valuable tool it's one of
those things that i go george has gone
on and off throughout his life i know uh
i don't know about gil he seems to be
one of the mentally healthiest people
i've ever come across but we all need a
little help sometimes all the time
whatever and having someone who's there
to talk for you is just one of the most
helpful things in the world which is why
we're very happy to be sponsored by a
place like betterhelp that offers you
resources for stuff like that so
betterhelp is customized online therapy
that offers video phone and even live
chat sessions with your therapist you
can have in there right at the moment
you don't have to see anyone on camera
if you don't want to
check
and it's much more affordable than
in-person therapy give it a try and see
if online therapy can help lower your
stress this podcast is sponsored by
better help that's h-e-l-p and omg high
listeners get 10 off their first month
at betterhelp.com
o-m-g-h-i
that's
t t e r h e l p dot com slash o m g h i
okay so you know about roger the doug
the peanut salesman i'm not sure you
know roger 48 38 years 48 years
yes if you're a fan everybody knows
roger
sure so roger was the peanut guy
this gentleman could take up two bags of
peanuts they used to be connected
and thrown behind us back to monrovia
from [ __ ] dodgers yeah
and he could if if you were
right
cross and up to the left he'd go like
this and he'd throw it and you'd catch
it in your
like in your palms and then he'd
remember who you were and come back
you're only 250. he was on the johnny
carson show that's how good he was he
was yeah they took him on they had him
as a guest on johnny carter's show
he's got a biography on amazon it's
called the perfect pitch
do you guys know that there's different
hot dogs now at dodger stadium they
change brands
do you know you know what i'm so glad
that you brought that up me too
it went from circumcised to
uncircumcision
it really did i mean what are they
thinking listen if you make your
[ __ ] reputation on a dodger dog yeah
it's like going to disneyland going
where's mickey mouse no he's not no
it's a [ __ ] cat now with a sweater
and nobody else can use the name and
nobody else so it's like where's where's
minnie
hey you know it's it's a mouse but a
feet but not
she wears different clothes just like an
inferior mouth like why how could you
change
that's like if you went to the vatican
and they go you still have holy water no
but we just
we just use like gatorade
we don't want people to get their
electrolytes you know
but there's to me there's no reason
because if it's such an institution or
people the things that people are used
to oh yeah and and
it's not like farmer john
is in new york where i thought you were
from it's over the freeway over the
other side
they're killing the pigs within the
distance of
the dodge of dodger stadium and for
money or whatever
they ch they went from grill to what are
they now steamed i mean it's a travesty
it's like i went last summer and i was
like that's like 90 of the reason i go
to dodger stadium and then i was just
like bought me for my house
one of these it's a big big ass roller
put the wheelies on and it rolls
themselves
7-eleven in the mirror
so they're grilled just right
that's right
you know how awesome that is to have
your own weenie roller in the living
room you're watching this
i wasn't on your bucket list
the other seven commercial stretch after
the seventh commercial everybody gets up
and they sit back down we have going
games on
right there yeah weenies are going you
still pay for it you're like all right
six dollars but but to change for
either savings
or for
health i mean listen
i mean they could have the option like
sure if you if you know there's some
freaks who want it steamed like let them
do that but it's like let the rest of us
live
if there's some freaks that's right they
should even have a steam line so that
way
you know that way you know who's over
there
like a predator you have to sign up and
every time you go to team steve
if you want a steam we need like a
sexual predator you have to register
yourself in dodger stadium and you're
over there don't come over here with
what's going on yeah
what's that guy's name phil hansen
chris hanson
a sporting event
and count calories exactly if you're
getting a hot dog it's like
you're already there you know it's like
why stop short like this you know the
problem with this country oh boy is
remember they used to have the thing
where you could pour your own
onions yeah and then they somebody had
this ingenious invention
of like making an old movie where you
turn it crank it and and the onions and
the relish would come out in perfect
portions oh man i'm so hungry and then
somebody put some mochas in there and
somebody found air
onions and now they give it to you in a
in a little thing you have to open up
like when you get out of a stub hub or a
door dash or whatever
and they don't even trust you to put
your own
onions on your own i haven't bought i
haven't
i haven't seen that yet
i've made the game this year but i
didn't but the devil's advocate is i
used to put the hot dogs and they'd go
hey fat ass let's go man five turns is
enough
[Laughter]
you're counting turns but my hot dog was
my grandmother would like just ketchup
and i was
mustard first
then the relish
and then the onions okay no ketchup no
ketchup
i was chatting on the ketchup
light very light on the relish
mustard and onions yeah but light on the
relish i didn't want the pickles to take
away the taste of the
everything else right yeah so i like
that we don't have ibs like that lady
that we had on everything
the way that ibs growing up now all you
kids have
i'm good
but you know what i mean like what was
yours okay i mean i hate to say it but
mine was ketchup and onions yeah wild
you know what that's some weird [ __ ]
though that's something
that's a weird combination that's almost
like leaves yeah it totally is i mean i
i like live ketchup
and onions it was honestly just i don't
even like onions that much i just like
to turn that thing
like i was like i want to get involved
wasn't that the best thing so good that
was
yeah i like it and now
what if you what if you like a lot of
onions and they only give you one of
those cereal yeah you're not going to
get out of your seed and go back and say
could i have five more of those
yeah no yeah
but that's a good point that you made up
the steamed ones and then they have a
vegan oh yeah i know
a vegan
what is that made out of
man they can't be what is that like old
sofas are they grinding them down that's
it
what is in a vegan you can tell what's
going to be seen if i can find it and
and and somebody that is vegan let's say
are you vegan you have any dietary
restrictions no
because now when you have a party you
have to call
oh yeah and say
it's grant's
party on saturday does anybody have any
dietary restrictions i can't eat
scallions
they're they're not invited and the food
can't touch greg doesn't like where the
food touches
i'm mexican i don't even know what a
scallion is
what mexicans man
[Music]
that's actually what i thought you were
saying
is plant-based for whatever is going on
with the vegan dog it's just it's a
plant-based dog it may be
you know the long green onions
you know okay
the onion the onion part is still onion
but the green part up on top that may be
the scallion part
that may be the scallion i think you're
actually pretty right
god we have no idea
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
do you travel as a comedienne yeah
um i was telling them i just got back
from mexico last night i did two shows
there
combo i'm a little embarrassed that she
works in mexico and i don't know
where did you perform
you could head there it's called
faustina los cabos i heard about that
club really yeah it just opened and how
is it and and it's all white people
there huh yeah
like i was like i was like oh no one's
gonna understand but it was all white
people just lived there
and they weren't even tourists
so it was like
a lot of canadians i got to hook up with
your people i got that trip to
the cobbles i bought you that trip yeah
yeah
um
were you at all intimidated by the idea
of working in mexico
no i performed in mexico city before i
told them um just once that didn't go as
well um and where was that
don't remember
don't recall they didn't speak the
language no
yeah yeah
but um where did they start yelling suck
it
okay they didn't do that to me so now i
kind of feel honored but they were just
like they're kind of just like
blank-faced like they're like we don't
know what you're saying you know do they
think that you're maybe somehow involved
with homeland security like i hope not i
mean in the moment i didn't think that
but now i do
so so and how much time did you have to
do because hey listen i'll say this if
you're up if you were a pilot let's
compare
stand-up comedy to learning to fly a
plane
let's say that and if you disagree at
any point
first you got to get in the air
yeah and then you have a runway that
runs out at a certain point
so you have maybe two maybe three
minutes to at least
get one in or two in
so that they know that you mean business
but then some people start slower
and by the time you get to five minutes
and you get a couple of chuckles or you
haven't really connected or you feel
like oh my god i gotta i'm gonna have to
move things around they know
and then it just becomes where they'll
pull back from you
yeah and even and they know you're
trying to gut it out but they're leaving
you hanging in right into it oh yeah and
two you show them
that you're worthy of them laughing yeah
i think that was a great comparison
i enjoyed every second and and in mexico
how did you where did you open with a
local one like
this past one i mean i just i think i
did a little bit of crowd work you know
just to start off yeah you know i i
usually just ease in it's hard for me to
just start that's my biggest problem i
just can't it's hard to just get up and
be like snap into it you know it feels
unnatural and it feels it does
aggressively who would say who would you
say that
is a comedian that would like just snap
into it
probably most professionals
george
that's what you do
but i guess it's like when they know you
you know and they just they want you to
start you know it's like when they don't
know you
it's a different journey it's a way it's
way different being a comedian yeah if
they don't know you it appears that most
comedians start out with involving the
the crowd yeah hey how are you doing
tonight here we are and you're getting
the
any couples
that would see two dudes they go
computer date you know that was back in
the yeah
together they'd go computer date
you know other thing yeah
and and uh so 2000 so that's 12 years is
pretty 12 years yeah are you do you like
are you a writer as well do you do you
see yourself as a um
i don't think you're you don't do skits
or anything do you like you like my
daughter annoying ass tick tock [ __ ]
skits that's her name where she gets my
ex-wife to sit on my lap
[Laughter]
you think tiger only had one femur
the uh
i'm not saying and i'm not laughing
thanks and you know what that leaves me
hanging and she's gonna say if you at
least had joined in
grant you [ __ ] never laugh anyways
stop watching porno what the [ __ ] you're
watching me
so uh uh so
self-deprecating humor can only be
achieved when you make fun of yourself
first
like i walk out and i go don't i look
like cheech [ __ ] chung
oh my god
see that's a good quick one yeah so
you're just yeah you're in it and then
and uh
and
what do you say you know i think i want
to see work
[Laughter]
because right because
yeah just like the other girl that was
here uh
which was the other one that was layla
the one then the one that was uh there's
lea lamar
she was one got a number of women on
over the months period you know jewish
girls never had ass when i was growing
up that's that's the one you're talking
about they got booty i like that
transition where do they come from
though
that's just they found it in the 90s
the valley
the
you know what just time means like when
you get older you get a fat ass but she
was young like all my ass got big asses
but
like she said in time
40 50 years
but they got them now like in their 20s
a big part of the proliferation of the
ass in our society now everyone you want
to show it off when
girls were
generalized but
comedians were not
like comedians were very attractive
you're attracted which is a sarah
friedman is another one uh which was
ferguson
that was married to prince andrew
natalie ferguson and uh do the
impressions
yeah
so they're definitely like you guys are
of a class coming up that are younger
and attractive
uh uh comediennes right yes i'll take it
definitely i'm not saying that by lunell
beautiful
but
you know um and they'll take over the
stage as soon as she comes out
yeah
but you can be fearless and still be
attractive
god bless
that should be your opening line
that's yeah that's you next time
because and and how far
yeah because when i was still working
during the day
in 1984
um
when
i think we discovered fire like middle
of 85
that
they asked me what is your goal in your
career
in 1984 and i said that i only wanted to
do the tonight show and if i did the
tonight show i wouldn't care if i did
anything else yeah
and i did the night show in 91 and then
can you imagine if i didn't care or do
anything else yeah
it's hard to you know it's hard to focus
on so many things
but and in order to do like you know if
you're looking at
when someone says you know if you're
working for a big company
and someone says
just let me get my foot in the door and
then maybe you can become an engineer
or you can become a designer or you can
become somewhere but at least you have
your foot in the door right and that's
what i think the 12 years are oh let me
get my foot in the door then i can
decide whether
you see yourself as maybe a sketch
person or
a tick tock person or one of one or just
a straight
you know straight stand up yeah
i mean i love doing stand up yeah like
i've been i'm taking the scenic route
like i haven't taken one shortcut but
you know what i like that i like i like
that about you yeah thank you and and
and you do you think in a in a
are you better in a 15 minute set are
you better than a 20 minute set or could
you get it done in 10.
[Laughter]
you know what you know what i'm saying
because something
starts a bit slower
okay so i feel like this is the first
year that because i used to be like you
know you get to a show and they're like
oh we're only doing 10 tonight and i'm
like yes you know because i know i could
kill it in 10. yeah and then it's like
you know there's no f like
part that'd be like oh i wish i didn't
have to do that you know but now i'm
like i need it well it's like i could do
it in 10 minutes like 20 minutes is like
you can't you know
that's the least amount i need it's like
yeah if you were to do 20
what were you how many topics could you
cover
appropriately in 20 minutes i mean i've
now just started doing some longer jokes
like i have like this like eight minute
mcdonald's joke and it's so nice to have
longer jokes you don't have to be like
jumping everywhere and people are like
wait what's she talking about now it's
like now we're just like keep it do you
know how [ __ ] hard it is to do an
eight minute it's crazy
that's longer than it takes to get the
food
so when i was in when i was in
sacramento working at the punch line
in the early 90s after we were done with
the points that we would go to jack in
the box
and when i went to the drive-through
that guy would say walk the jack in that
pocket and i tell you and i would be
like hi um is this jack in the box and
the guy
and i said uh can we have
uh four uh jumbo jacks and the guy would
say you want a yambo yak
and i'm like there's no
why in jumbo and i put it in my action
it became i put it on my on on an album
and i did it on my first television show
damn where i was talking to the clown
and i was doing the both you're asking
for fountain drinks on your joke and i
said i said what kind of fountain drinks
do you have he was like excuse me and
they were like it's soda yeah
but but an eight minute i mean you know
it's maybe six to eight depending on how
long i live in it but
it's nice it's just nice to be able to
like
breathe for a minute you know and just
not be so like jumping around and is it
i mean is that it
is that into the song
it's not yet
even even bob i think bobby slayton
who's been doing i think it was bobby
slayton
do you remember the lady that got burned
with the coffee the coffee
did it say piping hot no yes
so
he had a joke where the woman
got the coffee put it between her legs
which and then you drive off and the lid
was
not right and it burned her vagina
and then she sued mcdonald's and then
bobby's joke was she should thank
mcdonald's for getting her wet
but i love it but i thought it was good
that was good until you saw the ins it's
almost like will uh it sounded like
chris making fun of alopecia which
nobody should know
i mean i hope as a comedian that we
don't have to start looking at people's
men mental and uh dental records and
health records yeah but but
he's yeah when you saw the pictures then
all of a sudden on the music show the
pictures and then all of a sudden the
joke isn't as funny as
initially when he wrote it it was just
it was like a one-two yeah yeah then
people see the picture which was right
it scalded her and all of a sudden now
you think it's funny to make
fun of an old woman's vagina that
scalded and i would be i do but probably
most people you know
now and now we're [ __ ] dividing
people who can laugh at that stuff
exactly people who cannot laugh you know
for years comedians have made fun of
everything made fun of kids in
wheelchairs made fun of because it's
just
comedy yeah that's that's what it is you
separate the two do you remember that i
had my that thing where i said we always
had a little relative and they say push
your cousin and he was like i don't want
to push my cousin he goes push your
cousin to go to church or you go to like
and they're like what's your cut what's
your nightmare you're both of your
ladies
two [ __ ] two little ladies and you
don't want to push your finger
so it's like that like that's where i
came from like i appreciative bastard
you're walking around look at his legs
they've made fun of people for years
that's what comedy is it's to try and
make people laugh
when you start
also i thought special another one of my
jokes was i thought special need was a
bit insulting
to someone because latinos just make a
sound
and we're like how's your cousin which
one current
and you knew who it was
and i still do i still do that yeah and
they go where's kirk oh he made friends
with it remember the guy that used to
eat his hand there's someone there
so like like i
whether whether people like it or not
right it's not my decision that's theirs
but i have not changed the way that i
approach comedy in these in this climate
because if you do
yeah then it's like you can't change
horses midstream like they say right you
have to go with what you go yeah for and
if you
all of a sudden if you pulled your gun
and you knew that if you were to shoot
somebody
that it and it's just like you you can't
have anything in the back of your head
right right no it just it i i felt so
sorry more than anybody i felt sorry for
comedians around the world all of a
sudden you got to watch it was the
people in ukraine
if they can't laugh at it
okay
no no no but i mean yeah but i mean
every comedian has a has a line sure has
a line right and
i would say i just wish they'd stop
making fun of fat people
you know what as a latino you're a waif
sounds like you might be enjoying it
actually
if if my grandmother would see you
should go what's wrong with your friend
he's sick he's losing so much weight
what is he george 270 he made i tell him
to go to the doctor because he doesn't
look good at 270. i like him when he was
360. he was the the picture of health
so do do you are you're not married no
do you have do you have a boyfriend yeah
and and where did you meet him
comedy and he's a comedian too yeah
yeah
it's crazy right yeah
how did you guys decide that you guys
liked each other um i don't know we just
held a meeting one day and we just did
that and you felt it like you felt
yeah i met him i met him like a few
years before we started dating i met him
at a comedy festival in portland
um from portland no he's from northern
california
and then he moved down here we chatted a
few times and then you know
just worked out that way right oh yeah
it worked out great and and uh and how
is that your data uh
i think it depends on the person you
know because i you know dated some other
comic and that wasn't great but it's
just depend like we're both very
supportive of each other like his wins
are my wins my wins are his wins you
know and it's just fun
like that and they just blow each other
i didn't have it
i didn't have it like that
when i was
well i think it's kind of rare
it was rick glassman is his is his
girlfriend since you can't touch
anything in his [ __ ] apartment i went
over there
that
was the great glassman yeah yeah what is
the [ __ ] question
that that dude is
i got like i got
was he oc was he on the spectrum or what
yeah i don't know exactly how he defines
it but he has some sort of like he's
remembering the spectrum
i think he says he is
so do you remember when he came in
uh glassman with the curly hair he's
really oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah he's
funny isn't he he's still he's and he's
and he's how would you describe his
comedy
like he's very
a little bit absurd that's the one that
you identified as being ocd
yeah he well he was he moved all that
came in and moved all the cameras around
and to get the best angle and he would
go i should have done that and then you
and i are talking you go okay okay we're
gonna go to gil cut we're gonna put a
clip in there there we go so gil and he
does his own editing as he's doing this
now yeah but yeah in the time that we
were talking to him
because that's one thing that
i think about the podcast is i i'm
it's very my approach is very
unconventional i think
as to what and at the end it was very
emotional like i like i said i i get you
like i get
what you're going through and how
difficult it must be for you to get on
stage like i get it right because you
know even though he felt like he has to
do it he's very good right it's just
it's not
natural for him
right it's a lot of thought
a lot of a lot of thoughts
and uh i went over to his apartment
um
and i think a neighbor had yelled at him
right before he got oh really yeah
because you left the door open
right in his apartment building i don't
know
so so
with your first
boyfriend you could feel like there
wasn't a kind of like synergy or
somebody would say yeah yeah it's just
not fun you know and this this is just
way better would you guys travel
together or
no
we mean
your first other boyfriend oh i mean it
was it was
you know a bit too early in it but um my
boyfriend now he doesn't do as much
stand up he writes um like shut he up
they had at their own tv show oh good um
but it didn't air uh but now they're
working on another one so they didn't
know did they like it or just didn't
know yeah they ordered the whole season
they shot it edit it did everything
turned it in and then they didn't air it
oh wow yeah onward to b
no no a lot of money wasted should i say
tbs
tbs oh yeah yeah
okay yeah oh yeah if you change your
mind we can edit it
it's called the dress-up gang it's a
really really good show um and that yeah
they made the entire season
um i don't frankie quinones i don't know
if you know yeah
yeah yeah that's my boyfriend and they
made they made that show together the
[ __ ] out of your friend is your
boyfriend no no no no not frankie not
frankie not frankie my boyfriend's name
is donnie devonian but him and frankie
you know they make all the [ __ ] they
make all the videos with him yeah you
know
um
considering the expense of what goes
into prepare a show
to not air a show is really maybe
more than the ultimate
uh um
disrespect or evaluation of someone's
talent because when i was at tbs
they wanted to get into late night in
2007 or eight i started nine
but
jim peritori got restock who was working
on ellen in 2005 and we started to talk
about syndication from my first show
um
and i was kind of like maybe 50 episodes
in
but i didn't see the show ending in the
foreseeable future so i said hey man i'm
not worried about getting doing late
night [ __ ] i'm still over here he goes
yeah but you know this show's not going
to run forever and i was like well it's
not about forever but i mean it's not
going to end tomorrow
so when and i'd gotten to 120 and he was
working on ellen and alan was already on
and then he waited and i tried to stay
home a year and be married
i would rather [ __ ] shaman
at the bottom of the [ __ ] pool at sea
world i'm not going to laugh at this
you know one of these days again my
daughter maya said to me dad are you
ever going to get married and i said
listen out of respect for you because
you're a young lady i'm not going to
cuss i would rather die in my own car on
fire damn and she was like
that's right that was the tone down for
me and i said and
i have the ability to let myself out and
i still burn
oh
yeah
gill will take care of i'm not sure
i'm not sure if that's really the best
tribute to my ex-wife but but from my
point of view yeah
because what the mistake that people
make
in
relationships in business
and in in comedy is the [ __ ]
who are watching it aren't the
[ __ ] who people come to see
and when you gotta show like your
boyfriend show instead of letting the
audience decide there's somebody who's
has a slurred [ __ ] speech gotcha
that's not there anymore he was there
when i was there
and
they watch it and take it personal
instead of just removing yourself from
it right right and saying let's let the
audience decide let's not decide yeah
and that's that's the issue with if they
say oh i watched the show and i didn't
think it was that funny because you have
five hands up your ass every day damn
and you think something's funny and they
tell you it's not
and that's the issue with young
creativity like that show it's issue
with podcasts it's issue with i love joe
rogan but he's all all on the right hard
right is way more together than the left
and they're they stick together
and we don't because we're more artistic
we're liberal and they look at us as
weaklings or snowflakes or whatever the
[ __ ] we're supposed to be but
just because you're on the right and you
get a writing campaign or they
they send you know messages talking
about your support it's all bots [ __ ]
anyways yeah and we're the ones who
they try to you know suppress but and
and if you're gonna put that much money
into
uh a show on tbs let it let it run
you're already paid for it yeah yeah so
crazy well you can watch it on the tbs
app
that was the
two years later they they released it on
the tbs did they ever did they ever say
why
i don't they just i think they got
nervous about it like it's kind of like
a little bit out there even though it's
not it's actually just like a really
funny unique show but it's like because
there's never been anything like it i
think they got scared but it's like well
this is i mean they did get scared yeah
it's like so this is the first of its
kind like let it
tell me what was the format of that show
it was it was a narrative show it's just
you know the style is a little bit
different it's a little bit slower it's
a little bit um
not as like
i don't i don't even know how to
describe it
what is it uh
like when i think of like a fast comedy
or something i think like 30 rock or
something where it's like right it's not
like jokes the jokes aren't maybe so
obvious it's more of like a feeling and
the characters and was it sketch or was
it sitcom no it's a sitcom can we put a
clip up uh
there is clips on their youtube channel
okay
okay so yeah we'll drop something in all
right so check this out we're going to
start to
to to kind of have an opinion on whether
something should have been on or not so
let's look at the dress-up game
and what's the number i never can
remember that [ __ ] number uh 818 533
1843 so i'm sorry i talked to the last
part oh 818 533 1843 okay so people that
listen especially you too because you
like comedy yes all right
and you hate to uh disagree with a
[ __ ] that's married leave me
hanging three times already i've been
here no no i just don't want to get the
minutes
last time she came
up greeted me but hey but that but but
what that was you're married i'm
divorced you've been married 51 years
yeah 51. and he's afraid to laugh yeah
so he's known and i lost half of my
pumpkin i lost millions and i'm carefree
as a [ __ ] i i got to see your
daughter you know i don't know i don't
want to see
my daughter into this [ __ ] my
daughter sides with my wife anyways
under every situation
forget about wherever they live
that came from all right i'm on your
side there it is there it is
i got your back and you know i've been
doing this since i was 13. every time i
opened a drink i turned the can sideways
um
and it's the only thing my daughter got
from me not a [ __ ] nose or eyes or
color she turns her [ __ ] beard cap
sideways wait why do you do that it's
just a habit because when we were kids
and we'd go to parties that would be
drinking that that way i knew that one
was mine yeah and not to drink somebody
else and i still do it that was the
first beer i had with the
1931 right before the wall street
collapse
and 60 years before they discovered fire
but that's but what i'm but what i'm
trying to say is
that
let it let just let it [ __ ]
look at seinfeld seinfeld was called the
seinfeld chronicles really on nbc
and it aired and it didn't connect and
they canceled it
and then they kind of
dipped it up for like three episodes
really didn't do much to it yeah
and just called it seinfeld
and then it became seinfeld wow
but it would have gone away and i think
the dress-up game to me feels like it's
that kind of show where
it's not on the nose like like my show
wow the little girl can't swim because
she's on her period that kind of we'll
connect about a good clip that we could
throw up with an episode
or something about that i mean no one
wants to take big swings anymore
everybody's afraid to make a decision
wow they really are george where before
before
you would before you would
say
i like it
when when i was doing my show bruce
helford was working on drew carey
he got peter roth who was the president
of warner bros to come and see me
he came to the ice house and saw me and
he said i like him stu bloomberg was the
president of abc and that was the last
talent
president where talent came first not
numbers and not time slots and not
social media presence
and he came to see me and sat next to
peter roth and they both said let's do
it
and that's how it happened not some
[ __ ] with some testing
in l.a and testing in las vegas
and testing over here and someone said
they turn the knob where they don't like
you when you know you do say this and
they turn them out when they'll do this
they still do that yeah i mean that
that's an antiquated oas technology of
liking the show or not if you're the ne
if you're the president of a network or
if you're in charge of comedy
development and you
got there by making your decisions in
comedy and you see like the dress-up
game and you decide to just put it on
the [ __ ] what is it oh gang the
dress-up gang yeah what did i say i
think it's a game i think yeah that
might be better
maybe that's probably why
the dress-up gang
and let it run man let's [ __ ] people
and if it doesn't do well it's like okay
one season it's like it's not going to
kill you it's like have you seen what's
on tv like right now
was from the dominican republic yes he
was and he had like
129 hits in a row that [ __ ] used
to use bamboo to hit a baseball and
every time the dodgers were losing they
put him in
and he would get a base hit and the
dungeons would win like virtually what
was his percentage like in the 90s
right yep and
you would think there's no way that a
guy and he was
wasn't the best
wasn't the fastest runner
wasn't the best fielder he was a pinch
hitter yeah and he just knew how to
pinch it yeah
he didn't hit it hard
yeah didn't hit it far
but it's amazing and that's what that's
what i'm saying about tbs nobody
nobody's over there when i that when i
was doing my late night talk show
but they picked conan over me because of
look
yeah
and they couldn't get anybody of color
to be on that show and they would call
us just ask us do you think you can get
sam jackson to come on our show do you
think you could get
uh a far east movement like we had all
they were all if you watched my clips of
my talk show they were amazing yeah and
they just
couldn't get out of their own way yeah
that's a really good way to put it and
there was a guy i don't want to say his
name david hudson
said this on howard stern
and he was a coney he had his
[ __ ] nose so far up conan's ass it
probably that's why conan's hair
probably flipped to the [ __ ] left
this guy's nose up his ass
and he said to him he said to us in the
meeting
i think the comedy is getting a little
bit low brown
and i said uh what did you say
and he said i think it's getting a
little low brown and i said has anybody
ever bought a ticket to see you
perform
and he and he said uh i said you know
what [ __ ]
i've been in late night longer than you
we hired you so we were here first
and then we hired you and somehow his
opinion meant everything to tbs who was
in atlanta not even in burbank wow
and i said say lowbrow again
and i'm gonna jump over this [ __ ]
table and i'm gonna [ __ ] choke you
right here
david hudson you can validate the number
what's the number uh eight one eight
five three three eighteen if that didn't
happen you can call that but it's people
like that
that keeps shows that can make a
difference off television yeah like the
kangaroo gang over here
you know what i'm saying yeah it's like
you pay for it
put it on yeah and you know just because
like a show is popular and first run
like wings remember wings about the
thing so when my show was on
they didn't think i was going to be
it would be watchable in new york
because i was latino but mexican and new
york either more puerto rican dominican
and you know whichever guy would ride
the bikes and drop the food off ah
so
um
so so
uh
my syndication deal wasn't as lucrative
because the people who were in charge
thought that a latino comedian could not
relate to people
in new york
yeah she was like where are you getting
that like it's just like you know when
when it first came out
uh when you show first her i wasn't
watching tv that much i really wasn't
because of work i didn't i did didn't
get you're catching killers i love
watching
watching your show
today in syndication
i do
so you're the one yeah
but we knew and i and i so so
i'm going to advocate for the dress-up
gang yes awesome i'm gonna advocate
we're all gonna so everybody what's the
number again eight one eight five three
three eighteen four we're gonna watch
this show
we're gonna critique the shows
and if we can come to a consensus
that was my other joke that when latinos
these big words are all [ __ ] up i wake
up
if we that we will start a campaign with
tbs to put the dress-up gang on the
network and not on the app oh yeah i
think because people have tried to start
campaigns like just fans of the show
latinos don't start campaigning [ __ ] him
you get one person
right yeah that's right they say there's
a truck
that parks itself in the middle of the
street every day at 11.
that's how we do it million man march
african-american did that
latinos try to have it you know how many
people showed up
five
five
first two and as we're leaving two round
and the other three more
there goes this is where it was supposed
to be
but that but
there is a uh
there is a disconnect i think
in entertainment
that would usually have been
a support system like you want to see
[ __ ] do worse than you want to see
things do good and i say that as a cult
as a culture that we've gotten into
rooting for somebody to do bad
instead of wishing that somebody would
do good yeah you need to push them up
it's like the [ __ ] dodgers using the
computer programs to play baseball don't
remind me i wore my dodgers [ __ ] today i
know last first two out of three we got
to come back and what's the computer
saying start tomorrow the computers said
tilt they might as well [ __ ] unplug
him reboot my lego player
so so they so
um much like comedy
when you start a baseball game you don't
know
what's going to happen you got a pitcher
that might be the best pitcher in the
league he can get beat
but if you start playing by the numbers
you're going to get games by the numbers
and you're and the manager who's sitting
there like grand [ __ ] doesn't do
anything
and
you know the number like nine times you
look at
yeah a1a
i've noticed that about that
so instead of playing
baseball
you're playing situation ball
and instead of being a comedian you got
to write this down yeah that is going up
there and feeling it out and and
throwing them out like some [ __ ] just
you're just you know the notes like jazz
just play the [ __ ] notes you know the
notes
and instead you get a guy
that hits a fly ball and he should tag
up and go to third but he doesn't
because the computer said sixty percent
of the time you're not gonna make it
and to me that's not baseball damn it's
not peaceful and it's not comedy to see
a guy
here in l.a see a guy in san francisco
and see the same guy in denver and it's
the same act that's not comedy to me
yeah that's a [ __ ] recital i'll
give my [ __ ] violin
wow
well we got some homework we have to
wrap this one up because we're we're
short on time i'm getting started
i know i know i just well uh i i know
you just crashed out there bring that
[ __ ] in here
[Laughter]
but you know what i'm saying though
right yes yes it was just i just didn't
understand the minute you stopped
laughing at me you left me hanging like
you're right now
you left me hey you you're you're like
right now you're like [ __ ] ringo
no you just play drums with anybody no
and i'm in there we're like the beatles
over here and you'll just play with
anybody
has a question i didn't realize that
every city you go to you have a
different act every time you go to a
different way but i was trying to
maybe i missed she hasn't she maybe i
misunderstood it that's why i didn't
laugh
well i mean think about your profession
somebody's laying there you make a
[ __ ] chalk outline you go [ __ ]
college for that i'll chalk outline a
chalk body challenge huh
what do we do
who's got the chalk
[Laughter]
you know what i'm saying you know what
i'm saying though it's that we have
become so sensitive about comedy and so
[ __ ] threatened by uh uh um free
speech that we have to shut it down and
that isn't what
that isn't what we built this country on
no no exactly i'm with you 100 percent
120 percent
yes
how many percent do you watch
[ __ ] 12 percent
you know why you're because listen i
know you listen to the show i don't
listen to the show i do it i got a [ __ ]
to do i don't know the [ __ ] blue
beetle in atlanta i'm in a dc
franchise i started i don't need to be i
could be at
[ __ ] conrad's right now but if you
can
no no but but uh i didn't get a dc movie
though oh [ __ ]
i'm included in the blue beetle the
first latino superhero movie oh my god
it's me and gabriel
but he can't get off the out of the air
it's the first superhero that can't fly
and he's always making fun of me when
they make a movie about my life they're
getting gabriel to play music it's the
first superhero where you can't put your
arms around his ankles
but but um but i think in in um
in playing it safe
we're
going backwards oh hundred percent
yeah
where can i where can we see where can
we see you perform and don't say
flappers that's a [ __ ] you're better
than that
oh my god um
huh no no i'll be at oxnard levity live
this weekend
yeah
that's not this weekend is it the
weekend that she's oh
this will probably come out about uh two
weeks hey why don't you do it here let's
do a video so you can put it on her
social
media yeah don't look at me go ahead
girl
sir you will you do it
no grant you do it and i'll take them
here and then we'll do it and then you
can use us to to do the thing okay
so
in a few weeks uh in two weeks two weeks
okay
but where you at in a few weeks in a few
weeks well i'm going to be opening for
melissa via senor at the netflix as a
joke festival oh that's good yeah at the
um hayward theater
and how is she good i've never seen her
oh you haven't she's so good
yeah and is that all female comedians or
or
no it's just me and her oh good yeah
will you tell her that i would like to
meet her oh yeah of course yeah my
daughter as well and you so uh what day
is that uh that's april 29th perfect and
um
what can you be perfect this will be out
by then i can't even interfere with what
we're talking about she says between it
perfect
what about the dudes that do it if she
said
the podcast and it's on that same
[ __ ] month ours like three weeks
shit's going on in the world
yeah we're still covering [ __ ] we're
about two weeks
i think you should bump this one out i
mean we're still covering [ __ ] about
space shuttle
[Laughter]
oh you come over here go over there
we're going to do a promo for her oh my
god doing this live
damn maybe you're going to cut it out
anyways all right cool man
i think it's all going to get cut out
where do i go oh
wait
yeah where did he am i filming you it's
her she's good
we're doing it for her okay
again well what about if i just do the
oxnard one don't do that
um this weekend april
[ __ ] what's the date
yeah what are the [ __ ] things what's
the date
i don't know
april 17th 18th
possibly the 14th no 14 15 16 oxnard
levity levity live
why not what the [ __ ] going on you
better go here don't waste your time
anyplace else she knows that hey you
won't know what's going on until you see
her we don't know we're going for your
party she'll be there easter we'll go
pick strawberries now it's the out the
collection now all the stores are there
the collection now it used to be i've
actually never been to oxnard i'm just
so excited to be heading there you can
hear some jokes and go to creighton
barrow this weekend live and direct from
the valley all the way to hot start and
what's your name
chase bernstein
oh my god that was like iconic let me
send it to myself and then i'll pass
along okay yeah that's a oh my god thank
you that was so then you could mute
yourself and put new dates in
yeah just dab it over
oh my god thank you guys that was so fun
yeah it's really
fun so much
you